well I've been requested to do some
videos on Khan Katti and maximum and
minimum points and and inflection points
and all the like
that you normally see in your your first
semester of calculus course so I thought
I would start doing them but before we
we kind of go into the actual problems
that you might see in your book I just
want to give you a broad intuition
because in calculus class people they're
all these rules when you know the second
derivative is positive you're concave
this way when the second derivative is
negative you're concave this way and
people memorize the rules and then they
take the tests and if they memorize it
correctly they do well on the test and
then they forget it maybe they memorize
it again by the time of the final exam
but by the time they're 30 years old
they will have forgotten it and that
frankly is useless unless your whole
gold is just the past exam so I want to
give you some intuition and hopefully
you will never forget this intuition so
when you're first learning calculus
there's much more to functions than what
I'm going to do in this video but
there's kind of three types of
interesting points on most of the curves
we'll talk about so let's say let me
draw a curve let's say the curve looks
something like this you know if this is
the x-axis
us too thick that's the y-axis the curve
could look something like this I don't
know let me see it could look like this
and so on
right and if you have a curve like this
and you'll see all sorts of curves when
you do your calculation because you have
multiple degree polynomials etc what are
the interesting points well the
interesting points tend to be when the
slope is equal to zero so in this where
does the slope equal zero what are the
interesting points here let me make sure
I'm using the right tool right there the
slope is zero right because if you were
to take the tangent right there would be
like it would look something like that
right there the slope is zero as well
because if you took the tangent it would
look something like that and then right
there as well the slope is zero and the
line it really isn't a tangent it
crosses the graph but as we could see
the graph kind of flattens out there so
these are the three points that you tend
to deal with in your first semester
calculus class when you're graphing and
looking for
dreama and this is called a maximum and
in this case it's a local Maxima you
know if this was the highest point for
the entire function it would be a global
maximum this is a local minima and if it
was in you know if it was the lowest
point of the entire graph which the way
I drew it maybe this graph keeps going
up like that and keeps going up like
this so this would be the global minimum
point and this is called an inflection
point because it's neither a maximum
minimum but you kind of see that the
graph kind of in flex so let's study
them a little bit more and see if we can
get a little intuition on what happens
to the the graph the first derivative
and the second derivative at each of
these points so let's start with a
maximum point because maybe that's when
I say it's let start with a minimum
point because that's what we see the
most you know when we just studied y
equals x squared or regular parabolas
that was the most common thing we saw
and then of course if we have a negative
of a parabola it becomes like that but
anyway let's let's study a minimum point
where the graph is concave upward so
let's say we have a point like this so
that's the graph of the function right
let me you know I don't know what that
is it's f of X so what is happening to
the slope as we go from you know roughly
from here to there well let's try a few
points and see if we can by drawing the
tangent lines we had an intuition for
the slope so let's see if I pick this
point just randomly the slope it looks
something like that
I'm trying to do a tangent if I take
this point I'm just moving to the right
a little bit I'm just increasing my
x-value the slope will look something
like that if we so it's it's negative
here but if you look here the slope is
less negative right the slope is less
negative there and if we go to the
minimum point right there the slope
flattens out right and so of course the
derivative there would be zero and then
as we pass that point what happens well
here the slope is increasing a little
bit more and now the slope is actually
positive right
so the slope was negative less negative
zero a little positive and then we go
here it goes more positive more positive
so let's see if we can graph that let's
see what if we can just to get an
intuition of obviously I haven't written
any
members down so we don't know what the
exact value of the slope is so what does
the slope look like so here it's really
negative so the slope is going to be
something really negative here I'm just
picking a random point and then at this
point right here it was less negative so
the slope is going to be less negative
and then here roughly here the slope is
zero right the slope was zero and then
the slope gets a little bit more
positive and then over there it gets a
little bit more positive so the slope if
we were to if we were to actually graph
the derivative of the function at that
point it would be an upward sloping and
so I'm assuming this is the second
degree polynomial if this was third
degree then this would actually be a
curve so the slope will actually look
something like this right and does that
make sense we'll share this you know the
graph of this could be y is equal to I
don't know a x squared plus B and then
the derivative or you know f of X is
equal to ax squared plus B and so the
derivative of that of course would be
what is that - ax plus zero right so
this would just be a line and it
actually goes through zero zero but it
didn't have to but hopefully that gives
you a little intuition but now let's
move to the second derivative so the
slope of the slope let me draw it down
here the second derivative my wife is
coming homes I have to finish these
videos before she gets here otherwise I
have to continue it tomorrow see she
called five minutes ago stuff to hurry
anyway so this is f prime prime of X or
the second derivative so what's
happening to the second derivative here
well the second derivative is just the
slope of the derivative so what's the
slope well it's just a constant this in
this case it's just a constant upward
moving slope right so the second
derivative actually if we were to just
evaluate that it would be 2a so it's
going to look something like this and I
can actually it's going to look it's
just going to be a constant number and
it's going to be positive right
so in general when people you know when
you when when you study your extrema
points and say whether it's a minimum
more a maximum etc etc the way that you
think about it is well if if it's a if
it's a minimum point like this if it's a
minimum point what is happening to the
slope around it well the slope has to be
constantly increasing right even though
for example even though as we go from
here to here the value of f of X is
decreasing the rate at which is
decreasing is getting less so the slope
is actually increasing it's getting less
and less negative then it increases even
more so you you know you're at a minimum
point when the slope is increasing and
similarly you know that it's concave
upwards when the second derivative is
positive so hopefully that helps you a
little bit getting it get get the
intuition of what happens when you're in
a minimum point and you're concave
upwards well what happens when you have
the opposite well pretty much everything
becomes the opposite let's say that this
is your curve I don't know this is the
x-axis if that's your curve well here
you have a very high slope then your
slope becomes a little bit less then it
becomes zero then it becomes a little
bit more negative then it becomes more
negative right and then it goes more
negative the rate the rate of the slope
the slope becomes more and more negative
the whole time that we're kind of going
through this maximum point or this
concave downward so what is this what
will the slope look like well in this
example if I were to draw the derivative
the slope is going to look something
like this right
because back here the slope is really
actually a really high number it's going
to be up here and then as we get close
as we move further and further
increasing values of X the slope
decreases it becomes zero right around
here and then it just keeps decreasing
and then similarly if we were to draw
the second derivative what will that
look like well the second derivative is
just going to be the slope of this
function so it's just going to be a
negative number if we assume that this
is constant so the second if this is the
x axis the second derivative is going to
be something like that it's going to be
some negative number I'm assuming this
is zero zero anyway I'm about to run out
of well I'm not about to run out of time
but I think I don't want to rush it so
that's a maximum minimum point and in
the next video I'll give you a little
intuition on what happens with
inflection points and then we will do
a bunch of examples that you will
normally see in a calculus textbook but
I just wanted to do this for you because
there's nothing magical about a lot of
the rules that you will learn you know
when they say oh you take the text
second derivative and if the second
derivative is positive its concave
upwards and if the second derivative is
negative its concave downwards and you
might you know fill your brain with all
of these memorization x' but it's
hopefully if you think about it this way
fairly intuitive and it hopefully should
be fairly intuitive that whenever this
the first derivative is zero your slope
is zero and you're at a point that is
interesting at least in this context but
anyway I will do the next video on
inflection points and then I'll do a
bunch of actual problems see you soon